but now when you uh worked with great
martin scorsese uh your fashion tense
didn't cheer up the crew but you did
cheer up the crew well this is a story
it's a true story you know martin
scorsese of course well i i was in a
film that he was directing called the
age of innocence a very good movie by
the way
[Laughter]
and um
before it started you have to go in a
sort of costume parade and everybody
looks at you to see if the costume fits
the character and all that and i was the
very last person to be seen that day it
was a big cast loads of people you know
dan day lewis and michelle five you know
really important people then there was
you know that shoplifter winona ryder
i didn't i didn't like her i really
didn't
and there were lots of other people
um she didn't like her
richard lee grant who's adorable and um
and you know a lot of a lot of people
sean phillips and
and uh
hundreds of people and i was the very
last person and when i got in the room i
could see they were just exhausted the
whole crew they were slumped they were
tired they were fed up and i thought
i've got to do something to cheer them
up
because
when you see people in that state and
you know you're going to be working with
them and i thought i know what i can do
and so i stood up there and i just
lifted up my top
and tore off my bra
and my bosoms which are large and and
and friendly
and i
i just
gave them to them
and it made them happy
[Applause]
yes do you remember when we were when we
were shooting cold comfort farm yeah um
the the john schezinger movie um
you got stung on one of them by a bee uh
when we were doing that scene outside do
you remember that john patrick yeah and
you just took them out and said look and
and um and i said to john celestia
because i i said did you see miriam just
took her breasts out he said no but i
heard them hit the ground
[Applause]
[Music]